ukraine is proposing a prisoner swap
it's part of efforts to resolve a
standoff at the azov stars still planted
mario
the plan would see wounded ukrainian
soldiers exchanged
for evacuated rather in exchange for
releasing more russian prisoners of war
meanwhile ukrainian forces say they've
successfully pushed back russian troops
around the northeastern city of
some residents who fled the fighting
have begun returning to their villages
tatyana has returned to her village for
the first time in two months
but there's not much left of her house
her garden is littered with the
aftermath of russia's invasion
tatyana's goats at least survived the
onslaught
russians are our brothers
i could have never imagined anything
like this
this aggression
and destruction
when i came home i kissed the ground
now i have nothing
where am i supposed to live and what
should i do
neighbors in the village weren't spared
either
and also came back to find piles of
rubble where their homes once stood
but perhaps nowhere are the ruins
greater than mariupol after weeks of
relentless bombardment
russian forces and their separatist
allies are now in control of almost all
of the strategic port city
before rebuilding can begin
crews must first clear massive amounts
of rubble
i used to have three rooms now only half
of one
when i came up from the shelter i opened
the door and there was no apartment
anymore that was scary
residents who have remained behind are
now trying to get on with their lives
and in many cases that means improvising
the lone holdout of resistance remains
the azeptal steel plant where fighters
trapped underground have been
withstanding russian pounding
the ukrainian government has proposed
swapping them in exchange for russian
soldiers captured during their invasion
of ukraine
our correspondent army and asif is in
the west of ukraine in the viv
are there signs this prisoner swamp
could actually happen
it looks unlikely at this point ben
because russia has so far said it will
only swap prisoners of war for prisoners
of war
if you look at it this is an unusual ask
to swap
prisoners of war from the russian side
for on the ukrainian side combatants who
have so far refused uh to submit to the
russian forces to give up uh the azov
stall steel plant now they would be
suggesting to swap wounded prisoners but
russia does not see them as captives and
says that that's not playing by the
rules so so far not a yes from the
russian side and keep in mind that
russia is very fixated on a a victory
here at the style steel plant because of
the regiment that is defending it now
these are from uh they have far right
roots this battalion a lot of them wear
nazi insignia on their clothing so this
lends some weight to the false russian
claim that they're denotifying ukraine
and in russia this would be a big
victory if they were able to capture
that plant and either take them captive
or
essentially kill the people who are
defending that plant as
as of battalion but russia has also
swapped
ukrainian heroes of war including the
defenders of snake island
who
once told a russian warship
gave that an expletive and told it to go
away before they were captured
now the president has praised ukraine's
latest counter-offensive in the east
claiming that some towns have been
recaptured are the tables turning there
now this would be a big victory for
ukraine if it could secure harkeev which
is the second largest city we saw that
happen with the first largest city the
capital kiev where russian forces were
pushed out of villages and eventually
gave up trying to capture the capital
and that's what they're hoping to see in
harkev right now because these villages
have been liberated russian tanks and
artillery are not in range of firing on
that city which is a godsend for a lot
of people living there but russia
remains entrenched in the area so in the
east of ukraine and what you don't hear
a lot on ukrainian media is the
victories of russia severo donetsk which
is the largest city in the east that has
not been captured by russia has been
completely surrounded and a lot of
analysts are saying that that battle is
lost so that city will fall to russia
and russia seems to be shoring up its
victories in the east and securing an
area that it had mostly occupied already
since 2014 ben
ami and what about ukrainians did they
see some sort of end to this war
now zelensky said recently that uh they
need to be patient that ukrainians
cannot expect a victory every day or
even every week and as many people have
described it outside of ukraine it's a
stalemate but ukrainians at least here
in the west remain very confident that
they will win this war a lot of uh
ukrainians are now proposing uh
maximalist uh gains from this war saying
that they want to push russia completely
out of the east so morale is not broken
and don't forget that ukraine still has
hundreds of thousands of men that they
can call on uh to fight so uh this is
turning into a situation ben
like they've seen since 2014 where
russia is mostly confined to the east
it's something that they've been used to
and which they've already been dealing
with for many years and are willing to
deal with for many more years until they
can reclaim their country and secure a
victory over the invaders and that's how
they see it ben
ami and sf thank you very much for your
reporting from the viv
and for more on that we're joined by our
regular military analyst frank ledwidge
what's your take on russia's focus on
the east and southeast of ukraine first
up
well good morning ben two issues here
first of all your correspondent already
mentioned the importance of getting uh
getting the russians out of the
artillery range we've been out of
artillery range for a couple of days now
at least most tube artillery but there's
also another another purpose and that is
to strike at
russia's
lines of communication with that
southern front in other words the
ukrainians are now in range of russian
railways into the south
in the south east itself
the
russian offensive is continues to stall
yesterday the russians announced that
one arm of its media announced that the
town mentioned by a correspondent there
several donetsk is a fortress town
and i would suggest the reason for that
announcement is they're shaping people
for a lot of casualties in a long time
the city is um
russians are close they haven't made
much in the way of advances in the last
couple of days and some of your viewers
may have seen uh pictures yesterday of a
rather major strike by ukrainian forces
on a couple of bridges that's in another
part of donbass where the russians were
trying to surround ukrainian forces and
failed yesterday
and in the north east president zlinski
says ukraine's military is gradually
pushing russian troops away from hakeef
is ukraine capable of a full-on counter
offensive
it's shown itself to be fully capable of
retaking ground the issue around kharkiv
is i think that the russian forces were
fairly thinly spread they were clearly
there to provide a presence and
ukrainian forces for the last two two
and a half three weeks now been taking
advantage of that
russians have been pulling forces back
from don for them from don bus to try
and to try and show their is up but in
the medium term there's no doubt at all
the ukrainians are more than capable of
conducting counter-attacks but what they
need is that continuous stream of
replacement weapon systems and
strengthening weapon systems what
they've had up to now is enough to hold
what they need now are weapons that's
going to allow them to attack again they
need better tanks more tanks more
artillery more drones and replacements
for the systems they've lost
to come back to what you were alluding
to before the governor of russia's
belgrade region which borders ukraine
recently claimed one person died in an
attack from the ukrainian side kiev
hasn't claimed responsibility but could
the war spill over into russian
territory
kiev has
never claimed responsibility for any of
the unusual and unfortunate fires or or
or events damaging events have taken
place in russia and is unlikely to do so
but certainly they do seem capable of
helicopter strike attacks into russia
they've done that before apparently in
belgrade itself and possibly sabotage
attacks although
a lot of doubt about that in the rest of
russia so yes certainly ukraine's
capable of that just as much as uh well
perhaps more than we ever thought they
were
thanks for the insight frank lowitch
thank you
to belgium now where the first ukrainian
refugees are preparing to move into
specially built villages in cities like
antwerp and michelin the villagers
aren't designed as a long-term solution
but they are designed to meet the acute
needs of those fleeing the violence
little evelina's world just got a lot
brighter
pretty the three-year-old ukrainian says
in dutch and her grandmother ira agrees
apartment is very very good
thank you thank you thank you the family
is moving into a newly built unit in
antwerp's ukrainian village the first of
several emergency housing centers to be
built throughout belgium era marvels at
having their own kitchen and bathroom
after months in a shelter things that
once were normal can evoke extreme
gratitude when war steals your stability
project manager joe engelin says the
apartments are designed and furnished to
make these families feel good
we want to have a fully self-contained
apartment so everything that they need
is in it the builders put up these
screens symbolic of ukrainian
independence to beautify the environment
while the village remains under
construction but the families we met
didn't seem to see anything except a
safe space to call their own
the project's interpreter elona herself
a refugee says it's an amazing feeling
even for her in one moment
from nothing to own houses it's really
cool six-year-old akeem thinks so too
his mother eliza can explain in one word
what this apartment means for her family
freedom for elisa and her best friend
vida it's their second time as refugees
they fled eastern ukraine when conflict
broke out there in 2014. now they must
start over again
such trauma is one reason antwerp
authorities decided to build the village
even hiring ukrainian refugees to help
rather than spreading them throughout
the city give them a good feeling that
they are welcome here trying to get them
at least together to comfort each other
and to have some
link with ukraine and on the other hand
integrate them in our city but leaving
the ukrainian village to interact with
the wider antwerp community will be
essential to truly integrate and to find
work says researcher fatimas who's been
working with ukrainian newcomers so of
course it might be difficult for them
but the government
or the local authorities need to take
some extra measures to organize for
example language courses or some other
activities but in fact the village is
meant to be temporary everything even
its sewage system can be removed bart
bruleman says antwerp authorities will
reassess geopolitical factors in the
fall to determine whether the site is
still needed many ukrainians maintain
they want to go back to their country 22
year old alika alisa's daughter keeps a
virtual eye on their house in kiev every
day
alika says as grateful as she is for
this antwerp apartment it reassures her
to know their home in ukraine is waiting
for them too